Okay, so let's get right into it.
9 Things that Turn Off Potential Customers.
Listen, very rarely will anybody talk about
this.
I can almost tell you, you can't find many
articles or videos online that are actually
going to address these issues because it doesn't
necessarily help with subscription or fan
base or any of that stuff.
But I think it's so necessary.
If you're trying to be a professional entrepreneur
or CEO, if you're really trying to scale yourself
to the highest level, do you want to get all
of the weeds out of the way that are preventing
you from having a bigger, stronger relationship
with business people?
This is one of the things that I think is
going to be important to be thinking about.
Okay, 9 Things that Turn Off Potential Customers
#1 Somebody who smokes cigarettes.
Okay, so let's talk about cigarettes.
Why cigarettes?
So, this week, my father was in town from
L.A. visiting and we typically have a certain
sushi joint that we go to that I like in Dallas
and so this time it was closed.
So I took him to a new one.
I looked online and I saw a spot about a half
a mile away from my house that was 4 and a
half stars, 88 reviews, 4 and a half stars.
So, let's go to it.
So we went to this place and I'm sitting there
and the waiter comes.
The waiter comes, and he's standing a foot
away from me, getting ready to take the order.
I'm sitting, he's over here [to the side]
and I start smelling cigarette.
Heavy cigarette.
Immediately, in my mind, I'm checked out.
I'm never going to go to this sushi spot ever
again.
Now you may say, "Pat, you're judgmental for
doing that."
Not at all.
I'm the customer.
I'm buying.
I want to go to a place that I buy that I
feel good, and the service is good.
Now you may say, "Well Pat, how do you know
the service is bad?"
It's not about how I know the service is bad.
The mind is an imaginative mind.
So my mind immediately went to this.
My mind went to "Ahh, man.
He probably had a smoke break and he probably
smoked multiple cigarettes because he smells
pretty strong on the cigarette side.
And, I don't know if he's washed his hands.
He may or may not have washed his hands.
And he's going to go out there and carry my
plate and he's going to bring my plate.
And I'm going to hold it and I'm going to
smell the cigarettes.
And it's going to bother me.
I can't eat the sushi.
So in my mind, we stayed, because nothing
else was open.
This was Memorial Day weekend.
Nothing else was open.
The bill ended up being $121.
I eat sushi twice a week.
The other sushi spot that I like to go to
is 4 1/2 miles away from my house.
This is a half a mile away from my house.
Watch this.
$121.
Let's just say that I go there once a week.
$121 times 52 weeks in a year.
You know how much money that is?
It' roughly $6300 per year.
If I go there for five years, five times $6300,
that's $31,000 they lost over a five-year
period.
If I go to sushi spots, I always take friends
and family.
So imagine the people that I take to introduce
to this sushi spot, okay?
That adds another $60,000.
That's $100,000, $90,000 potentially this
restaurant owner lost that he doesn't know
about.
You see if I owned a restaurant, one of my
first questions would be, "Do you smoke cigarettes?"
Because customers don't like smoking cigarettes.
Their imagination goes to a whole different
place.
So #1 is cigarettes.
In sales, if somebody comes to my house and
they want to sell me something, and I smell
the cigarettes, I'm automatically checked
out because I can't wait for them to leave,
because I don't like the smell.
And believe it or not, most people don't like
the smell of cigarettes.
I'm not trying to harp on this.
I did a Facebook Mentions a couple of weeks
ago and I brought this up.
Somebody got very upset about the fact that
I said cigarettes, but it's just the reality
part of it.
You lose a big chunk of business by smoking
cigarettes, if you're in the -- now if you're
business is all purely calling and no one
can smell it, thank God, they can't smell
the cigarettes over the phone.
But if it's something you're touching people,
you've got to realize that it's effecting
your business.
#2: Odor
Hygiene.
Let me explain what I mean by odor/hygiene.
Yellow teeth.
Yellow teeth is a turnoff when someone is
buying something from you or doing business
with you.
This is if you are in the service or sales
business or you're in the sales world or business
where you're an entrepreneur, where your image
matters a lot.
Your entire image matters a lot, right?
So odor.
Let's talk about odor.
Yellow teeth is a by product of what?
It's either alcohol, coffee or it's cigarettes,
right?
So all those three cause yellow teeth and
it could be a part of you not brushing your
teeth twice a day.
It could be a part of you not doing teeth
whitening, all those stuff could be a part
of it.
It's a turn off in the world of business.
Another part of odor is B.O.
- body odor.
The challenge with body odor is, you will
rarely know if you have body odor because
you don't smell yourself.
You've been with yourself for 25 years.
You're not going to smell your own body odor.
But generally, you know how everybody has
a friend that's pretty honest with them?
Or a relative or brother or sister or a family
member.
Ask that person.
Don't ask the person that's afraid to tell
you the truth.
Ask the person that's pretty direct.
Look what they'll tell you.
"Yeah, you smell a little bit."
Okay, great.
Right?
Does that make sense?
Now I know that I need to adjust.
So body odor.
Shower twice a day, once in the morning, once
at night.
Don't go to sleep without showering.
Wake up in the morning with a shower.
Just make sure your body odor is.
. . and if you're going to do body odor, maybe
shower with something that has as decent scent.
Another one is an excessive amount of cologne.
Some people you know, you go to a nightclub
and everywhere it's cologne, cologne, cologne,
thinking girls like this.
Gentlemen, cologne goes like this -- once
here boom boom boom boom boom (on one wrist,
rub wrist together and then wrist rubbed on
face) boom, boom boom.
That's it.
You don't need any more than that.
When you do too much, you're over compensating
for something you are hiding.
That's all part of B.O.
Body odor and hygiene.
Next, one of the turn offs and why you lose
potential customers is small lies.
When you're telling a presentation and you
catch a lie here and a lie here [snaps finger]
you lose me.
I'm automatically not doing business with
you because if you can tell me three, four,
five lies in a row, you're probably going
to give me a big lie as well, right?
So I'm paying attention for things that are
inconsistent with the presentation you're
giving.
So it's very important for you to not have
any small lies being done in your world as
you're doing business.
Next one, #4, too pushy.
If you're too pushy, people don't like too
pushy sales people because it reminds us of
car salesmen or reminds us of certain whatever
it is.
. . too, too pushy, I don't like.
I'd rather have you take a little more effort
than try to push me on buying something, which
I'm going to cancel tomorrow anyways, so what's
the real benefit of you pushing me to buy
something today, right?
Then the complete opposite side is like right
now, people said, "Yeah, I'm not like that,
this is why you know, my customers love me."
Yeah, but you're not closing them much.
So your effort also doesn't work.
Then there's the people that are way too soft.
This is the 5th turn off.
Way too soft.
[spoken with a soft, timid voice]: "Would
you like this?
Do you want to buy this?Do you wan to give
us a shot?
What do you think about this?
Is this okay?"
That's also a turn off, because my feeling
when I see that energy is that you don't even
believe in your own product.
I want someone that's assertive.
"So John, is there any reason why we shouldn't
do business together?"
"Um, yeah, there is.
I have a concern with this."
"Okay.
Tell me what are your thoughts on this area?"
Instead of, "Why don't you buy it today?
Why don't you buy it?
C'mon, man, let's buy it.
C'mon bro, let's buy it today."
No.
No, no, no.
Questions.
And then there are people that are too soft
and say, "Oh, you don't want to buy it today?
Sounds good.
Thank you so much.
Thank you."
I don't want that either.
I want you to make an effort to close me,
right?
I don't want you to be too pushy, I don't
want you to be too soft.
#6: Looking somebody in the eyes.
It's very important that somebody looks me
in the eyes.
People like it when someone is able to look
at you in your eyes because they're not hiding
anything.
Here's what I do.
Here's who I am'm.
. this is what I'm doing.
I've got nothing to hide.
If you want to do business, great.
It's a turn off if you do one of this [looking
down] all the time.
If you can't look people in the eyes, and
there are people that do, how do you feel
about it?I don't feel good about it and neither
do people who want to do business with you.
So when you're talking to somebody, "How are
you doing, John?
It's a pleasure meeting you."
Boom.
Look a them in the eyes, okay?
Next, delivering on promises.
Let me explain what I mean by delivering on
promises.
If I do business with somebody and they tell
me, "Oh, the moment I leave this place, I'm
going to send you an email with a draft" and
all this other stuff, you should get it within
the next 30 minutes.
If I don't get that email, but I get it a
day later and they use this sentence, "You
know, I got caught up yesterday.
. . " Anything they give me is an excuse.
Anything.
That person's probably not going to deliver
on their promises.
And they're thinking about this.
"Oh, tomorrow I'm going to have my assistant
call you and get all this stuff started."
I don't get a call tomorrow from the assistant?
Don't bother calling me the next day.
If you're a professional have your assistant
call me tomorrow.
And remind them and hold them -- oh, you know
what, my assistant sometimes, you know.
. . No, it's not your assistant, it's you.
You messed it up.
By the way.
These are mistakes that you make that somebody
points out to you and you've got to improve
as well.
I'm simply telling you on areas that you may
be losing business that you need to get sharper
in.
Next, facade, authentic.
When I'm trying to buy something from somebody
and they're not being themselves, it's too
much of a "Well, let me tell you who I am.
Let me tell you.
. . " It's too much of a facade and it's not
themselves, it's a turn off.
It's too fake.
We don't like that.
We don't want to do business with somebody
like that.
I had a guy that I did business with.
"I'm the best mechanic in Upland."
The best mechanic in Upland.
I had an issue with an S600 of mine and I
said, "Look, I'm selling the car next week,
but it's got an issue with the check engine
light.
You've got to fix it."
He said, "No problem.
He goes and looks at it and comes back, "Oh,
there's this major issue.
You need a part that I can get, but it's going
to cost us $2500 to get it" and he knew I
was selling it the next week, right?
He knew that I was selling it next week because
he was the mechanic of a family member.
So I said, "No problem."
I had no choice so I had him do it.
And I go get it, and I drive it back.
The next day the S600 gave me problems again.
I took it to my local guy because Upland was
an hour and a half away from me.
He said, "Patrick, I don't want to. . . is
this person a relative?"
I said, "It's someone that my family introduced
me to."
He said, "I hate to come in between you and
your friend, but I just want you to look at
this real quick."
So I went and looked at it and he did the
whole shimmy job, you know what I'm talking
about.
And tied it up.
And I called him and said, "Look at this,
what did you do here?
My family introduced me to you.
What type of a business person are you?
Is this how you do business?"
"How dare you tell me.
. . " I said, "This is the second day.
This gave me problems.
There's nothing that's been changed.
Tell me what you changed."And he said.
. . "I said, "That's not been changed."
I had the mechanic talk.
. . . and he hung up.
And that was a mechanic that was used.
That's not transparency.
That was a facade.
It was an act.
He lost my business and many people's business
around simply because he tried to get fast
money and abuse the customer.
And then the last one I'll tell you, some
people have a hard time explaining this part,
but I'm going to try to do my best to explain
it in a way that will hopefully make sense
to you.
You know, sometimes.
. . I was on Facebook Mentions this past Sunday
night.
I normally do Mentions on Sunday night at
10:00, Central Standard Time, 8:00 Pacific,
11:00 Eastern, and we have hundreds of people
that join us on Sunday night.
And one of the guys asked me the question,
he said, "Pat, how much does weight have to
do with me being successful?"
And I said, "Weight with you having to be
successful?"
and he said, "Yes, weight."
I said, "Okay, it's a great question.
It's a tough question because I'm going to
give you my honest opinion."
He said, "Tell me."
I said, " Look, whenever I am buying something
from somebody who is dramatically out of shape.
I'm not talking about 10% above your body
weight that your body can carry.
If your body can carry 150 pounds and you're
at 160 pounds, okay, I get it.
165, I get it.
But if your body can only carry 150 and you're
230 pounds, you lack discipline.
Now I know that today's world in America is
so sensitive, so sensitive, that people are
very quick to post a message on the bottom
saying, "Shame on you.
It's offensive.
You're insensitive. . . . and you don't care
about people.
All you care about is business."
No.
I watch people who are extremely overweight
and I've had dinner with them, and I watch
their habits.
Two cheesecakes, all this bread, all this
heavy stuff, at 8:00 at night.
What are you doing have two cheesecakes?
You can't afford to have another cheesecake.
"Oh, I'm just going to do it today" is their
famous line.
"I normally don't do this.
I normally do salad, but just today, just
today, another cheesecake, another cheesecake,
another cheesecake."
And they're wondering why they're 50, 60 pounds
overweight.
It's an energy issue.
Listen, let me explain to you mathematically
how I see this.
"Pat, what does this have to do with business?"
Everything!
Because if you don't have the discipline to
take care of the body that you're going to
live in for 80 years, what makes me think
you're going to have the discipline to take
care of me as a customer for three months?
Or six months.
Or 12 months.
I did business where two people were buying
and selling a house for me.
One of the people that was selling a house
for me - this person was not in shape.
At all.
Probably 100 pounds over their body weight.
This other person that was my real estate
agent, this person ran five miles a day, worked
out four times at the gym, and exact, great
body shape.
This person was 15 years older than this person.
This person had kids and grandkids and everything
that they were taking care of.
This person did not.
Watch this.
Every single time I called the out of shape
person, not one time did they pick up the
phone call.
Every single time.
I called this person, they always picked up
the phone call.
Maybe a phone call like this, "Hey Patrick,
I'm on the other line with a customer, can
I call you back in 10 minutes?"
No problem.
I could never get this person to pick up the
call.
It's laziness.
It's, "I'll do it later."
It's that mindset.
Why?
Mathematically, watch this.
If this cup [picks up a cup] can only carry
16 ounces and I try to force myself to put
50 pounds on top of this, what'd going to
happen with this thing?
It's going to get crushed, right?
This body of mine is created to carry a certain
amount of weight.
Anything above that -- and I've experienced
this -- my body can carry around 225 - 230
pounds.
So if I'm at around 240 - 245, I'm good.
If I hit 255, my body struggles to carry this
30 pounds.
Now imagine if someone were 150 and their
240.
The body is carrying 90 pounds additional
that they can weigh.
That's like constantly doing squats and you're
walking around all day with an additional
90 pounds.
Can you truly effectively work for 13 hours?
No you can't.
You may effectively work for seven hours.
You're yawning at 3:00 in the afternoon.
That's success.
That's business.
That's when the real guys get to work.
I mean, the real competitors get to work -- they
start early, but they're getting to work at
three, four, five o'clock.
I mean, they're like, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, 11.
They put their kids down and they're working,
ten, 11 o'clock.
When it's 12:00, they're still working and
boom at 5:30 in the morning they're up!
Let's get to work!
Because the body is picking up what it can
carry.
So I'm not trying to tell you this, and believe
me, many people on this video are going to
love to share this video with other people
because they're afraid to say what I'm saying
in this video.
But it's the truth.
I've run a sales organization now since I
was 21 years old.
And every single time that I sat with a guy
that was going through this, or a gal, and
I pull them aside, and I would tell them,
"You know I love you.
You know I care for you.
You know it's not just business here.
I want to see you win as well.
I looked at your numbers, and I'm telling
you, every time I watch you get tired too
early.
You get tired too early.
You give up too quick.
Somebody on the phone call says, "I'm not
interested," you hang up.
Every time you go out on an appointment, the
smallest thing happens, you can't wait to
come back home.
And I said, "Your weight is an issue.
You need to drop around 30 pounds.
And I'm telling you right now, you dropping
30 pounds -- your income is probably going
to go up 50 - 100 percent next year if you
drop this weight.
"Oh, Pat, you know.
. . " typically the reaction is all positive.
"Pat, you're right, man.
I've been promising myself to go out there
and get in shape.
. . " so it's not like they're coming from
a place -- and I'm not trying to embarrass
anybody.
But man, your weight plays a big role.
If you're an athlete in sports, and you put
on 50 pounds, Clippers, Lakers, they're all
going to get rid of you.
You're not going to play in the NBA for too
long.
In the world of sales an business, you know
who fires you?
Not the Lakers.
Not the Yankees.
Your customers fire you every single day by
saying no to you.
And you don't even know it.
It's a turn off.
And it's something that you can control.
To all my sensitive folks out there that are
going to say, "Shame on you because you don't
now what it is to be big boned."
I don't know what it is to be big boned?
Maybe I don't know what it is to be big boned,
but I know what it is to not eat pizza.
The last time I ate a Big Mac was in 1997,
September.
How do I know that?
Because I finished boot camp.
And when I finished boot camp, I went out
and ate a Whopper and a Big Mac the same day
and threw up all over the place.
And I used to work at Burger King.
So I had many Whoppers and many Big Macs.
I feel lethargic after I eat a Big Mac.
I may eat a slice of pizza or two, maybe once
every two months.
Because I know I'm now I'm now thirty some
years old, closing in on forty, and when I
eat, I feel heavier.
My body keeps it now.
I used to drop it but it keeps it now.
These are disciplines that you actually can
do something about.
And I guarantee you that people want to do
business with somebody where the vibration
and energy is high.
They feel good about it.
They do, and your weight plays a big role
in it.
So nine things that turn off potential customers.
And to some of you that had the guts and the
courage to watch the entire video here, and
some of it is pertaining to you [claps hands],
I applaud you.
I don't know you.
You don't know me, one on one.
Maybe we don't have a relationship.
Maybe we do and this will never come up to
you and I.
But I want to applaud you.
I want to applaud you.
Because it starts off with us wanting to address
areas that are sensitive areas to want to
improve in that area.
If you didn't like anything I had to say today,
you are more than welcome to unsubscribe -- although
-- if you can throw me my pillow -- man, I
hope you don't, because we have a goal, by
August 31, our goal is to get to 100,000 subscribers
on Valuetainment.
I believe our channel is second to none on
YouTube.
I see a lot of YouTube channels that are about
entrepreneurship . I see many of them that
are about entrepreneurship.
But it's a lot of motivation.
You can do it.
You should do this, you should do that.
But I don't see a lot that's about how-to.
This is why I believe we can go pound for
pound with any YouTube channel on entrepreneurship
so if you haven't subscribed yet, please do
so.
If you're one of our loyal fans, loyal followers,
please get your friends and peers and other
entrepreneurs to subscribe as well.
And if you're watching this video on a completely
different website that it's embedded to, you
can always come back to PatrickBetDavid.com
and if you have questions/comments, comment
on the bottom as well.
Thanks for watching.
Take care, everybody.
Bye, bye.